Dans la vie et parfois au travail,
on passe son temps à prendre des décisions
et ce qui les rend souvent difficiles c'est qu'il y a toujours
une part d'incertitude ou bien de risque dans le résultat.
Par exemple, vous décidez de souscrire, ou pas,
une assurance ou bien une extension de garantie,
vous jouez au loto peut-être
ou bien vous faites des placements.
Ou bien tout simplement vous vous demandez
s'il est raisonnable de prendre l'avion
sachant qu'il a une certaine probabilité de se crasher.
Aujourd'hui on va voir comment notre crétin de cerveau
raisonne quand il doit prendre une décision
avec une part d'incertitude.
♪ [Générique] ♪
Commençons par une expérience très simple,
je vous propose le choix suivant :
soit je vous donne 500€ tout de suite,
soit on tire à pile ou face, pile je vous donne 1000€,
face je ne vous donne rien.
Qu'est-ce que vous préférez?
Face à un choix de ce genre,
la quasi totalité des gens, plus de 80%,
choisissent de prendre les 500€
et de ne pas jouer à pile ou face
et pourtant voilà comment on peut analyser ce problème.
Dans le premier cas, je gagne 500€, ok.
Dans le second cas, je gagne,
soit 0, soit 1000 à 50% de chance
donc vous voyez qu'en moyenne ça fait 500€ aussi.
On pourrait penser que les deux choix
reviennent au même et pourtant non,
les gens préfèrent majoritairement le choix certain, non risqué.
Et ça va même plus loin que ça, puisque même quand
on augmente un peu la valeur du choix risqué,
la majorité des gens continue de préférer le choix certain.
Pour voir ça, on va retrouver les expériences
de mes deux auteurs préférés dans crétin de cerveau:
Kahneman et Tversky.
Ils ont proposé à des sujets le choix suivant :
soit recevoir 3000$ sûr et certain,
soit recevoir 4000$ mais à seulement 80% de chance.
En moyenne le choix risqué est plus attractif
puisque 80% de 4000$ ça fait 3200$.
Et pourtant les 4/5 des gens ont pris le choix certain
et seulement 1/5 le choix risqué.
Intuitivement, on pourrait se dire que c'est parce que
la nature humaine n'aime pas l'incertitude,
le fait de ne pas savoir exactement à l'avance
les conséquences de nos actes, de nos décisions.
Mais pourtant cette explication ne tient pas.
Regardez sur cet exemple,
Kahneman et Tversky ont retourné le problème.
Imaginons que vous vous preniez une grosse amende.
Vous avez le choix entre deux options:
soit payer 3000$ avec certitude,
soit avoir 80% de chance de payer 4000$
mais 20% de chance de ne rien payer du tout.
Qu'est-ce que vous préféreriez, honnêtement?
Et bien dans cette expérience, 92% des gens
ont pris le choix incertain, risqué.
Même s'il semble être le moins intéressant
puisqu'en moyenne il fait perdre 3200 dollars.
Cette expérience montre bien que le problème
n'est pas que les gens fuient les décisions risquées
ou bien qui comportent une part d'incertitude.
Au contraire là, ils se jettent sur l'option à l'issue incertaine.
Et pourtant, ce qui est fascinant, c'est que les sommes en jeu
sont exactement les mêmes que dans l'expérience précédente.
Simplement, dans cette expérience,
on parle d'une perte au lieu d'un gain
et c'est ça qui modifie complètement
notre attitude face au risque.
Quand il est question d'un gain, les gens ont tendance
à fuir les options incertaines et à préférer les choix certains.
On parle d'aversion au risque.
Mais, quand il est question d'une perte,
les gens ont tendance à préférer les options risquées.
On parle d'appétence pour le risque.
Et ça, ça se produit même quand les deux options
comportent une part d'incertitude.
Par exemple, qu'est-ce que vous préférez,
gagner 3000$ avec 90% de chance
ou gagner 6000$ avec 45% de chance ?
Alors, en moyenne, c'est totalement équivalent,
dans la deuxième option, on gagne deux fois plus,
mais la probabilité est deux fois moindre.
Les deux options comportent une part de risque...
mais pas la même
et les gens choisissent à 86%
la première option, la moins risquée.
Maintenant, si on retourne le problème,
qu'est-ce que vous préférez,
perdre 3000$ avec 90% de chance
ou bien perdre 6000$ avec 45% de chance ?
Et bien là, 92% des gens ont pris le choix le plus risqué.
Le fait que notre attitude face au risque ou à l'incertitude
change suivant qu'on parle de gain ou de perte
peut paraître un peu irrationnel,
mais la théorie de l'économie comportementale
permet de l'expliquer.
♪ [Générique] ♪
Commençons par les situations de gain :
Il y a un élément essentiel à prendre en compte
pour comprendre notre attitude face au risque,
c'est l'idée de perte de sensibilité au gain.
Si là, tout de suite, je vous donne 1 million...
Ça va vous faire très plaisir.
Mais si je vous donne 30 millions
et puis que, finalement, je vous annonce
que ce n'est pas 30, mais c'est 31 millions,
honnêtement ce million supplémentaire,
vous vous en foutez un peu.
Et oui, 1 million, ça n'a pas la même valeur
suivant ce qu'on possède déjà.
Amusons-nous à traduire cette idée de valeur des gains
avec une mesure de plaisir ou de satisfaction.
Les économistes ont un mot savant pour ça,
ils appellent ça l'Utilité.
Si je vous donne 500 euros, mettons
que ça vous fasse une satisfaction de 12.
Si je vous donne plutôt 2 fois plus, 1000 euros,
votre plaisir ne sera pas doublé, ce sera
moins que 24, peut-être seulement 18.
A 1500 euros, disons 22
et puis à 2000 euros, mettons
que vous ayez une satisfaction de 24.
La courbe de satisfaction en fonction du gain augmente
de moins en moins vite. On dit qu'elle est concave.
Et c'est la concavité de cette courbe de satisfaction
qui explique pourquoi on préfère
les gains certains aux gains risqués,
même s'ils seraient équivalents en moyenne.
Si je vous donne 1000 euros, selon cette courbe
votre satisfaction serait 18.
Mais si je vous donne soit 2000, soit 0, à une chance
sur deux, votre satisfaction sera 24 ou 0
donc seulement 12 en moyenne.
Avec des courbes de satisfaction concaves,
La satisfaction moyenne est toujours
inférieure dans le choix risqué
même pour un gain moyen en euro qui est identique.
De manière générale, la concavité
des courbes de satisfaction,
c'est-à-dire le fait qu'on devient de moins en moins
sensible à une augmentation des gains
explique parfaitement pourquoi
on a une aversion aux risques
et qu'on préfère les choix certains
plutôt que les choix risqués,
du moins quand on parle de gains parce que
quand on parle de pertes, c'est l'inverse.
De même qu'on devient de plus en plus
insensible à un gain supplémentaire,
on devient de plus en plus insensible aux pertes.
Si je perds 1000, j'aurai un certain déplaisir,
mais si je perds 2000, je n'aurai pas le double
de déplaisir, ça sera un peu moins.
Cette fois, on dit que la courbe des pertes est convexe
et si je raisonne sur des choix risqués, il se passe
l'inverse de ce qu'il se passait sur les gains.
Le choix risqué est, en moyenne,
plus attractif que le choix certain.
Vous voyez donc que notre comportement,
en apparence paradoxal,
de fuir le risque quand il s'agit de gains
mais de le rechercher quand il s'agit de pertes,
s'explique très bien à partir de 2 ingrédients.
Le premier, on vient de le voir, c'est cette idée que l'on
devient de moins en moins sensible aux gains et aux pertes,
qui se traduit par la forme des courbes de satisfaction.
Le deuxième est très important, c'est le fait
que l'on juge toujours les choses en relatif
comme des gains ou des pertes
par rapport à notre situation de référence.
Cette dépendance à la référence,
j'en avais parlé dans une vidéo précédente
et on avait vu qu'elle pouvait conduire
à se faire assez facilement manipuler
et bien quand on rajoute des choix incertains
ou risqués, c'est encore plus paradoxal.
Kahneman et Tversky ont soumis le problème suivant.
Une épidémie se déclare et
600 personnes sont touchées,
vous êtes en charge de décider du traitement à leur
administrer et vous avez le choix entre 2 possibilités.
Traitement A, 200 personnes seront sauvées.
Traitement B, il y a 1 chance sur 3
que les 600 personnes soient sauvées
mais 2 chances sur 3 que personne ne le soit.
Face à ce choix 72% des gens
préfèrent le traitement A, le choix certain.
Puis à un autre groupe de sujets, on soumet
le même problème, mais avec des traitements différents.
Traitement C, 400 personnes vont mourir.
Traitement D, 1 chance sur 3 que personne ne meure
et 2 chances sur 3 que 600 personnes meurent.
Et là, 78% des gens préfèrent le traitement D,
celui qui est risqué.
Ces résultats sont totalement cohérents
avec ce qu'on vient de voir.
Quand on parle de gains,
les gens préfèrent les choix certains,
mais quand on parle de pertes,
les gens préfèrent les choix risqués
Le hic c'est qu'en fait, les 2 situations que je viens
de vous décrire sont exactement les mêmes.
Regardez, le traitement A,
c'est la même chose que le traitement C
et le traitement B, c'est exactement
le même que le traitement D.
Le simple fait de présenter les chiffres différemment
en parlant, soit de personnes qui survivent,
soit de personnes qui vont mourir
a fait passer les gens d'un comportement
où ils évitent le risque,
à un comportement où ils prennent des risques
et ça, rien qu'en changeant les mots utilisés.
Tout ce qu'on vient de présenter là reflète assez bien
la manière dont la plupart des humains
se comportent en situation d'incertitude
et pourtant, il y a un truc qui cloche.
Si cette analyse était parfaitement correcte,
personne ne jouerait jamais au loto.
♪ [Générique] ♪
Oui, le loto, c'est une proposition du genre,
payer 1€ pour avoir 1 chance sur 1 million
de gagner 1 million d'euros,
c'est-à-dire une perte certaine pour un gain en moyenne,
au mieux équivalent mais très incertain.
D'après ce qu'on vient de voir, on devrait
totalement fuir de genre d'offre
et pourtant il y a plein de gens qui jouent au loto
ou à des jeux d'argent, comment on explique ça ?
Une des raisons avancées par Kahneman et Tversky
est le fait qu'on a beaucoup de mal
à percevoir les probabilités.
Pas seulement à les calculer numériquement, mais
même quand on nous donne les chiffres déjà calculés,
à correctement les interpréter
et à les prendre en compte à leur juste valeur.
Notamment dans nos raisonnements, on a une tendance
naturelle à surestimer les faibles probabilités,
à leur donner une importance exagérée.
Il y a une expérience qui montre ça très bien,
qu'on appelle le paradoxe d'Allais.
On a vu tout à l'heure qu'entre 6000€ à 45% de chance
et 3000€ à 90% de chance,
les gens préféraient majoritairement le choix le moins risqué,
mais imaginez que je vous propose le choix suivant.
6000€ à 0,1% de chance ou 3000€ à 0,2% de chance.
Vous choisissez quoi ?
Si vous êtes comme la majorité des gens,
vous choisissez l'option à 6000€
et c'est un peu paradoxal, parce que la situation
est la même que précédemment,
d'une option à l'autre on a 2 fois moins de chance
de gagner, mais un gain potentiel 2 fois plus élevé,
donc logiquement, notre attitude devrait être la même.
Intuitivement, l'explication c'est qu'on a du mal
à faire la différence entre 0,1% et 0,2%.
Quand on voit ces chiffres, 3000€ à 0,2% ou 6000€ à 0,1%
ça a l'air d'être à peu près la même probabilité de gagner,
donc on choisit le gain potentiel le plus élevé, 6000€.
Pour bien mettre en évidence le côté paradoxal
de l'affaire, on peut faire une troisième expérience.
On propose aux gens le jeu suivant, il se déroule en 2 temps.
Première étape du jeu, vous n'avez rien à faire,
rien à décider, c'est juste un tirage au sort
et vous n'avez que 0,2% de chance
d'aller à la deuxième étape.
Si vous atteignez la deuxième étape,
vous aurez le choix entre 3000€ avec certitude
ou bien 6000€ à 50% de chance.
Vous ne savez pas encore si vous allez aller
à la deuxième étape, le tirage au sort n'a pas eu lieu,
mais vous devez dès maintenant choisir
ce que vous y ferez au cas où vous y alliez.
Si on propose cette situation aux gens,
ils vont faire abstraction de la première
étape qu'ils ne maîtrisent pas
et raisonner sur la deuxième et ils vont choisir
majoritairement l'option la moins risquée, logique.
Et pourtant, pris au global, ce jeu en 2 étapes est
exactement le même que celui que je vous présentais avant.
Au final, on doit choisir entre 0,1% de chance
de gagner 6000€ ou 0,2% de chance de gagner 3000€.
Pour une situation, au final, parfaitement identique,
le simple fait de décomposer différemment les probabilités
fait que les gens peuvent passer de l'option
la plus risquée à l'option la moins risquée.
Kahneman et Tversky ont essayé de comprendre ça
en illustrant la manière dont on déforme
les probabilités dans nos perceptions.
Sur ce graphique, je vous représente la probabilité
perçue ou ressentie si vous voulez
en fonction de la probabilité réelle.
Quand les probabilités sont faibles on a tendance
à ne pas bien faire la différence et à les surestimer
donc notre probabilité perçue ressemble à ça.
Et c'est pour ça qu'on continue à jouer au loto, parce qu'on
surestime la probabilité réelle de gagner qui est minuscule,
je crois que c'est 1 chance sur 14 millions
avec le loto classique.
Et évidemment on commet l'erreur inverse
avec les probabilités proches de 1.
Si je vous dis que quand vous prenez l'avion
vous avez 99,99999% de chance de survivre
et que quand vous prenez la voiture
vous avez 99,999% de chance de survivre,
vous allez vous dire que c'est à peu près
la même chose et pourtant ça ne l'est pas du tout.
Donc pour les probabilités proches de 1,
on a aussi cet effet d'écrasement
qui fait qu'on les considère un peu toutes pareilles.
On n'arrive pas à se convaincre que quelque chose,
comme le fait de survivre en avion, est quasi certain.
A ce stade, on pourrait penser que ce phénomène
de déformation des probabilités
est lié au fait qu'on a beaucoup de mal à manipuler
de très petits chiffres, comme les millionièmes,
mais en fait, on n'a pas besoin d'aller
jusque là pour que l'effet se manifeste.
Kahneman et Tversky ont fait les expériences suivantes.
Première expérience, 3000$ avec certitude ou 4000$ à 80% de chance, celle-là on l'a déjà vue
et 80% des gens prennent le choix certain.
Seconde expérience, 3000$ à 25% ou 4000$ à 20%
et bien déjà là, les attitudes sont renversées.
20% ou 25%, pour beaucoup c'est pareil,
alors que 80% ou 100% ce n'est pas pareil
et pourtant les ratios sont les mêmes.
Comme tout à l'heure, on pourrait réécrire
la seconde expérience en 2 étapes.
Première étape, tirage au sort avec 1/4 de chance
de passer à la deuxième étape
et ensuite, soit 3000$ avec certitude
ou alors 4000$ à 80% de chance.
Donc vous voyez qu'avec des probabilités
pas du tout négligeables, 1 chance sur 4 ou 5,
le phénomène de déformation
de notre perception se manifeste déjà
et modifie notre attitude face au risque et à l'incertitude.
Au final, notre courbe qui représente les probabilités
ressenties en fonction des probabilités réelles
ressemble, en gros, à ça dans les extrêmes
et entre les deux, on est à peu près bon
pour percevoir les probabilités
même si on peut imaginer
tout un tas de variantes à cette courbe.
Au final, cet effet de déformation
de nos perceptions des probabilités
fait qu'on peut avoir une attitude face au risque qui est
différente de celle que prévoyait l'analyse précédente
et, par exemple, on peut accepter des pertes certaines,
comme payer 1€ pour jouer au loto
dans l'espoir de gains très incertains dont on n'arrive pas
à correctement assimiler la probabilité.
On entend parfois que le loto est une sorte d'impôt
sur les gens qui ne comprennent pas les probabilités,
mais ce que nous montrent Kahneman et Tversky,
c'est que ce n'est pas tellement une question de compréhension
mais plus une question de perception, de pondération.
Quand je vous dis que vous avez 1 chance
sur 14 millions de gagner au loto,
il n'y a rien à comprendre, il n'y a pas
de maths à faire, il n'y a pas de calculs,
c'est juste une question de correctement
intégrer cette probabilité dans nos raisonnement
et c'est ça qu'on a du mal à faire.
Tout ce que je viens de vous raconter là se résume dans ce que Kahneman et Tversky ont appelé,
"La théorie des perspectives".
Vous savez, au début de la vidéo, je vous expliquais
qu'on pouvait analyser les choix incertains,
qui comportent des probabilités, en regardant
ce que ça rapporte en moyenne.
Si vous avez une probabilité de 5% de gagner 1000
et une probabilité de 95% de perdre 100,
le résultat moyen est, 5% de 1000 + 95% de -100
et ça fait -45, donc en moyenne ce n'est pas très intéressant.
Petite note, depuis le début j'utilise le terme de moyenne,
mais les mathématiciens ont un mot pour ça,
ils appellent ça l'espérance du gain.
Faisons un peu d'abstraction.
Dans ce genre de choix, on considère
une probabilité P1 d'avoir un résultat X1
et une probabilité P2 d'avoir un résultat X2
et les résultats peuvent être
des gains positifs ou des pertes négatives.
L'espérance est donc (P1 x X1) + (P2 x X2).
Quand on évalue l'intérêt de ce choix, on a vu qu'on
ne juge pas proportionnellement les gains et les pertes,
mais à cause de notre diminution de sensibilité, intuitivement,
on les remplace par la satisfaction
qu'elle nous apporte, ce qu'on a appelé l'utilité.
On peut appeler cette fonction U
et on a vu la forme qu'elle pouvait avoir.
Et enfin, quand on évalue les probabilités, on ne sait pas
non plus correctement les prendre en compte
et on les pondère par une fonction S
qui écrase les probabilités faibles et élevées.
Donc voici ce que nous dit la théorie des perspectives.
Quand on nous soumet à un choix incertain,
qui comporte une part d'incertitude,
on effectue bien une sorte de moyenne
intuitive avec les probabilités,
sauf qu'on déforme à la fois les gains
et les pertes mais aussi ses probabilités.
Ce qui est étonnant dans tout ça, c'est qu'au final, on l'a vu,
on peut avoir des comportements
qui sont irrationnels face au risque,
qui dépendent de la manière
dont on nous présente les choses.
Pourtant, la théorie des perspectives
nous montre que ces comportements irrationnels
sont reproductibles, on peut les mettre en équation,
c'est-à-dire qu'ils sont d'une certaine manière prédictibles
et ça c'est intéressant parce que ça veut dire
qu'on peut les étudier scientifiquement,
mais ça pose aussi le risque de se faire manipuler avec.
Donc, essayez de penser à ça la prochaine fois
qu'on vous propose un choix avec une part d'incertitude.
Merci d'avoir suivi cette vidéo.
N'hésitez pas à vous abonner
pour ne rien rater des prochaines vidéos
ou retournez voir les vidéos précédentes, notamment
toutes celles de la série "Crétin de Cerveau".
Vous pouvez suivre les actualités de la chaîne
sur Facebook, sur Twitter
et vous pouvez, pour ceux qui le souhaitent,
me soutenir sur Tipeee.
Merci, et à bientôt !